você já sentiu aquele tremor Zinho na
pálpebra do olho que aparece do nada e
logo desaparece às vezes ele vai e volta
causando um certo desconforto esse
fenômeno chamado de espasmo nas
pálpebras é causado por pequenas
contrações musculares que na maioria das
vezes são totalmente inofensivas e
também passageiras então esses espazos
podem acontecer tanto na pálpebra
superior quanto na inferior do olho
embora sejam mais comuns na parte de
baixo e sim geralmente não há o que se
preocupar com isso não tem motivo para
grandes preocupações mas vale a pena
prestar atenção pois pode ser um sinal
precoce de algo maior na maioria dos
casos esses espasmos estão nos avisando
que algo simples precisa de atenção
Talvez uma boa noite sono que você não
tá cumprindo reduzir a quantidade de
cafeína ou simplesmente tirar um momento
para relaxar porém no entanto em
situações mais raras esses espasmos
podem ser um sintoma inicial de
deficiência de vitaminas e minerais ou
até mesmo de condições mais sérias como
doenças autoimunes esclerose múltiples
espasmo hemifacial entre outros
problemas existem diferentes tipos de
espasmos nas pálpebras que variam em
frequência gravidade e causas
subjacentes Mas todos têm em comum o
fato de afetar a musculatura da pálpebra
e em alguns casos até a área ao redor
dos olhos um tipo bastante comum é a
bioquimia que é aqu espasmos esporádicos
e leves que geralmente ocorrem na
pálpebra inferior eles são comuns e
geralmente inofensivos mas se começarem
a persistir e a interferir na sua rotina
diária é o sinal de que talvez seja a
hora de procurar um profissional de
saúde outro tipo é o blefaroespasmo
essencial Benigno que é um espasmo
crônico que afeta ambos os olhos sendo
mais comum em mulheres e em pessoas
entre 50 e 70 anos com o tempo esses
espazos podem se intensificar levando a
sintomas como visão embaçada e
sensibilidade à luz já o espasmo
hemifacial afeta apenas um lado do rosto
e é causado por uma pressão em o nervo
facial inicialmente os espasmos são
leves Mas podem evoluir até afetar todo
o lado do costo o espasmo da pálpebra do
olho costuma a ser unilateral ou seja
acontece apenas um lado do rosto embora
casos bilaterais onde ambos os óleos são
afetados também possam ocorrer mas são
bem raros a duração desses espasmos pode
variar de segundos a horas e eles podem
surgir de forma intermitente ao longo do
dia ou até se prolongar por semanas
especialmente em climas frios e se você
for mulher então quando esses espasmos
se tornam prolongados é o que chamamos
de mioquimia pobral crônica mesmo assim
é importante lembrar que esses espasmos
benignos não causam atrofia ou fraqueza
muscular você ainda será capaz de abrir
e fechar os olhos normalmente sem
problemas então se os seus olhos começar
a tremer preste atenção em quanto tempo
isso dura e se está afetando ou não as
suas atividades diárias Porque se os
tremores persistirem ou se tornarem mais
severos pode ser hora de buscar a ajuda
médica para entender melhor o que que o
seu corpo tá tentando te dizer então
quando falamos sobre as causas um dos
principais fatores para esses espasmos
oculares leves intermitentes É o
estresse quando estamos sob muita
pressão o nosso corpo aumenta a
liberação de neurotransmissores como é o
caso da adrenalina que pode acabar
estimulando os nervos e desencadeando
esses espasmos o cansaço Especialmente
quando os olhos são forçados a trabalhar
mais que o normal como no caso de
estudantes que passam horas e horas
estudando ou profissionais que passam o
dia todo na frente do monitor do
computador pode facilmente levar
episódios de tremores oculares Outro
fator que merece atenção é o uso
excessivo de cafeína consumir grandes
quantidades de cafeína ou de café outras
bebidas cafeinadas pode aumentar a
estabilidade dos nervos resultando em
espasmo nas pálpebras o álcool também é
um vilão ele pode entrar nessa categoria
onde o consumo excessivo pode
desencadear tremores embora o fumo
também possa contribuir o álcool tende a
ser um fator mais prevalente mais
significativo a secura ocular é outro
aspecto importante a ser considerado
óleos secos ou irritados seja após
longas horas de Exposição à tela sem
pausas adequadas seja após uma crise
alérgica e até por doenças como a
síndrome do olho seco e a doença
autoimune chamada síndrome de jogr tudo
isso pode levar espasmos isso acontece
porque o corpo tenta proteger os olhos
com piscadas frequentes e esse esforço
Extra pode resultar em tremores além
desses fatores algumas condições
específicas podem causar espasmos
temporários por exemplo a conjuntivite
pode causar ex tremores durante o
período de
inflamação episódios em xaque ca são
outro gatilho comum e para algumas
pessoas para algumas mulheres
especialmente as alterações hormonais
durante o ciclo menstrual podem aumentar
a frequência desses espasmos além dos
gatilhos mais conhecidos como estresse
fadiga e consumo excessivo de cafeína Há
outras causas menos faladas mas
igualmente importantes que podem levar
espasmos nas pálpebras as deficiências
nutricionais Então essas deficiências
podem impactar de forma significativa a
função muscular e a função nervosa
contribuindo para aparecimento D
tremores oculares uma das principais
deficiências que causam isso
relacionados à condição dos óleos
tremendo é a magnésio o magnésio é o
mineral essencial que desempenha funções
neuromusculares atuando como regulador
dos impulsos nervosos da contração
muscular então quando os níveis de
magnésio no corpo estão baixos os nervos
podem ficar excessivamente reativos isso
Vai resultar em espaos musculares
inclusive nas pálpebras então a falta de
magnésio é portanto uma causa comum
embora muitas vezes é uma causa
subestimada que vai causar esses
incômodos tremores outro nutriente
fundamental pra função neuromuscular é o
potássio ele ajuda a regular o
equilíbrio eletrolítico e a condução dos
impulsos nervosos então quando há uma
deficiência de potássio uma série de
sintomas poem surgir incluindo fraqueza
muscular câimbras e claro os espasmo nas
pálpebras assim como magnésio o potássio
é essencial para manter a estabilidade
muscular e também a estabilidade nervosa
e sua falta pode levar a essas
contrações involuntárias então Magnésio
e potássio são importantes tem também o
cálcio que é outro mineral Vital pra
contração muscular adequada e pra
transmissão dos sinais nervosos então
níveis baixos de cálcio podem também
causar espazos musculares câimbras e
ocasionalmente tremores nas pálpebras a
deficiência de cálcio pode ocorrer
devido a uma baixa ingestão desse
mineral e também devido a problemas na
paratireóide ou até mesmo pela falta de
vitamina D de dado que é necessária
paraa absorção do cálcio pelo corpo
absorção e metabolização do cálcio pelo
corpo além dos minerais as vitaminas
também desempenham um papel importante
na prevenção dos espasmos nas pálpebras
é o caso da vitamina B12 que é
fundamental paraa saúde neurológica e
muscular então a sua deficiência
deficiência admitir calamin de B12
especialmente se essa deficiência for
longa for prolongada pode estar
associado a uma variedade de sintomas
incluindo o tremor da pálpebra outra
vitamina relevante a B6 ou piridoxina
que também é essencial pra função
neurológica E além disso é fundamental
paraa síntese neurotransmissores como é
o caso da serotonina e a dopamina quando
os níveis de vitamina B6 estão baixos ou
estão muito baixos o equilíbrio
neurológico pode ser afetado isso Vai
resultar em irritabilidade muscular
também com espasmos incluindo na região
das pálpebras quando os temores e os
espasmos nas pálpebras se tornam
contínuos ou começam a interferir de
forma significativa na sua vida é hora
de prestar atenção a causas mais sérias
em alguns casos certos medicamentos
podem estar atuando pode ser o caso de
ser o responsável pela mioquimia da
pálpebra
de que medicamento nós estamos falando
como antipsicóticos anticonvulsivantes
bloqueadores de canal de cálcio e até
alguns que são usados no tratamento da
doença de paxo eles podem induzir esses
espasmos além dos medicamentos uma
tireóide hiperativa ou é o caso do
hipertiroidismo excesso de funcionamento
tiroidiano também pode ser uma causa
secundária dessas
tremores infecções virais que afetam os
nervos também podem levar a espasmos e
contrações musculares persistentes
também pode ser infecções no ouvido
médio otite média ou até infecções em
estruturas que envolv o ouvido médio com
a mastoidite podem ser fatores
desencadeantes em casos mais raros
espasmos ou fasciculações que não
desaparecem pode ser um sinal de
condições neurológicas mais graves que
podem afetar os nervos uma das mais
conhecidas é doença autoimun esclerose
lateral meot trófica que é uma doença
progressiva que afeta os neurônios
motores outras condições a série
consideradas são doenças autoimunes
doenças sistema nvoc Central como
esclerose múltipla ou ap de tumores que
podem em alguns casos específicos
desencadear tremores também temos a
paralisia de Bel que causa fraqueza
temporária ou paralisia dos músculos de
um lado do rosto que pode igualmente
resultar em mioquimia palpebral
condições neurológicas como a doena de
paxon e aino de turet também estão
associadas a ex tremores oculares se
você estiver experimentando espasmos
oculares em situações específicas é
essencial consultar um profissional de
saúde especialmente se você notar alguns
dos seguintes sintomas se o seu olho
estiver vermelho inchado ou apresentar
algo em comum se a pálpebra superior
estiver caída se o olho estiver
completamente fechado a cada contração
se os espasmos persistirem por várias
semanas ou se começarem a afetar outras
partes do seu rosto embora a maioria dos
espasmos nas pálpebras desapareça Sem
tratamento em poucos dias se isso não
acontecer algumas medidas medidas que
você pode adotar para tentar eliminar ou
diminuir as causas potenciais por
exemplo reduzir o consumo de cafeína é
um passo importante assim como garantir
que a sua dieta esteja balanceada e rica
em nutrientes essenciais como é o caso
dos minerais que nós falamos magnésio
potássio e cálcio que podem ajudar a
prevenir esses espasmos oculares ou
musculares Além disso assegurar que você
esteja dormindo o suficiente sono
adequado pode fazer uma grande diferença
manter os olhos lubrificados também é
crucial usar um coliro de venda livre
por alguns dias pode aliviar o
desconforto e aplicar uma compressa
morna nos olhos quando um espasmo começa
também pode ajudar a relaxar os músculos
Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração
Você é fera